doctors are intensifying efforts to find
out what caused groups of people in two
different cities to mysteriously develop
a rare eye cancer ocular melanoma
typically occurs in just six out of
every 1 million people we met for
friends who went to Auburn University
and were all diagnosed with this same
rare disease a growing list of people
from the area developed the same cancer
at least 18 other people with ties to
Huntsville North Carolina were also
diagnosed with ocular melanoma and a
Warner is here with an update to the
story we first told you about on Monday
and a good morning good morning so after
our report aired Monday
hundreds of people reached out on this
and they said that they either know
someone or they have had themselves this
rare cancer one of the four women we
interviewed Ashley McCreary had
previously set up a Facebook page for
people with this cancer that has now
drawn comments from people around the
world having the CBS you know air Monday
morning was just we were blown away all
day long with texts and emails
Ashley McCreary says the most common
reaction she's been getting from people
who saw our previous report on ocular
melanoma is hope I don't know if you've
ever been through something by yourself
but it the worst place to be is alone
and so this has been able to provide
people just a family one of those people
is Kayla almond from Tennessee the 30
year old was diagnosed with ocular
melanoma this past September she
underwent radiation treatment and lost
nearly all the vision in her right eye
she saw our story about Ashley and three
other women who attended Auburn
University who are battling the same
rare eye cancer do you feel like you
have a part of that group Allison alread
our affiliate wiat in Birmingham which
has been following the story since last
year spoke with dr. John Mason who is
treating already most recently in the
last year too I've seen more cases of
melanoma that I've seen in the previous
21 years we don't know why doctors are
hoping
or people coming forward may help find
more answers ongoing studies in North
Carolina have not revealed a cause of
the increase in ocular melanoma cases
there and funding for new studies in
Alabama has been hard to come by both
the state of Alabama and Auburn
University declined to offer funding the
university has set up a task force but
Allred says more needs to be done well
it's real important for us to have the
money to even begin the research and
without the research there's not a
chance of us finding the cause or the
possible link McCreary and Allred hope
more attention will generate more
funding and ultimately save lives we've
just been so pleased and so thrilled
that the awareness is happening the
possibility of funding is more likely
now that we're getting some attention
and we're excited about the direction
it's going well mccrary's doctor is an
oncologist in Philadelphia they said
that they've gotten so many calls since
the story aired they've had to separate
out a phone line and create a dedicated
phone line just to take the calls we're
calling about ocular melanoma so
hopefully all of this and the idea is
get more research get more fun funding
first in the research get more research
going and maybe help find a cause why so
many young women and other people maybe
people hope that there are others with
with this disease well that's sort of
think about it and they're saying sorry
media you know connects everybody
together and gives them a sense that
there's other people they can talk to
you like this strikes me it's so
important though that you told the story
that you brought the story so more
people can come forward and get help you
know I hope really hope they do